[Música]
meu nome é muito nobre gum
sou artista pesquisador e professor da
escola de belas artes da ufrj
esse é o espaço com um prédio da
reitoria onde fica localizado o
laboratório ea idéia aqui é é abordar
esse assunto né a questão da educação
fala da caixa e tentar trazer algumas
idéias a respeito disso
e pra falar disso eu vou voltar um pouco
em 2005 quando estava fazendo doutorado
que tinha essas motivações dessa
experiência está falando no país e
aprovando aprofundar nas questões é
sobre a arte na sua relação do trabalho
de arte o artista é um observador é esse
foi o meu supervisor goiás que tinha
idéias sobre cibernética e aplicou essas
idéias na arte na década de 60 sobre
interatividade
sobre a idéia de uma arte é que não era
só um objeto fixo mas objeto que teria
comportamento que responderia a esse
observador né e é bom
a idéia do da pesquisa basicamente era
pensar esse objeto de arte é como ele
funcionaria como um catalisador de
energias na verdade pensar a obra de
arte o trabalho de artes não apenas com
um objeto que estava na sua frente mas
ele na verdade é um nome uma rede mais
complexa nessa relação de que está
fluindo esse objeto é então ele faz
parte de uma rede de relações de caráter
afetivo isso é um ponto importante é a
arte não se de se resumir o objeto em si
mas levaria de um campo invisível de
forças a ideia pensar essas relações
invisíveis que gira em torno do objeto
que dispara essas relações
então para isso a idéia é pensar a arte
como um sistema não é uma ideia minha já
vinha de alguns alguns teóricos alguns
artistas pensadores sobre a arte é eu
trouxe essa idéia da arte como hiper
organismo né a um trabalho de arte é
seria um
é alguma coisa que você cria e que têm
um desenvolvimento no tempo e evitar
ligado sempre uma rede principalmente no
contexto atual né das conexões é quem
tem em torno desse objeto hoje que você
faz alguma coisa tá na rede está em
tempo real acontecendo então eo insight
foi pensar é dentro desse sistema para
ativar essa relação afetiva trazer um
organismo vivo pra dentro desse sistema
bom é a idéia de trabalhar com o
organismo vivo não é uma ideia é já foi
abordado por outros artistas por exemplo
um trabalhador do caqui é que um
brasileiro que trabalha o conceito de
bill arte por exemplo trabalhando com
bactérias bioluminescentes ou então o
trabalho da mesa que trabalha com essa
borboleta é mudando geneticamente a
configuração da asa para criar padrões
artificiais né padrões é na borboleta a
partir das suas ideias ou então por
exemplo o trabalho dessa barata que
controla esse robô néon com robô que é
ele caminha de acordo com a aabar ata
que você tem aqui um conjunto de luzes
que acendem na barra funda na frente uma
barata quando ela encontra o robô
encontra obstáculo isso faz com que a
barata ela ande para trás ao movimento
em cima desse mouse e as coisas comando
e assim o robô é bom e eu ficava
perguntando o que seria esse organismo
vivo né é ea idéia de que deveria ter
essa potência de ativar sua própria
existência é tais relações ou seja eu
queria alguma coisa que por si só fosse
um sistema e que trouxesse em si alguma
informação para esse observador do
caráter sensível afetivo
bom aí vem essa história eu vou trazer
pra vocês que durante a pesquisa eu tive
o conhecimento dessa pesquisa do crime
baxter que foi um cara que na década de
60 ele é ele é um agente da cia e ele
resolveu não sei porque chegar no
escritório dele nós
e colocar um polígrafo né ele trabalhava
com um detector de mentira ele coloca
esse polígrafo é é uma planta porque ele
queria saber quanto tempo levava para a
água chegar até da raiz até a folha e
achou que é dar uma gráfica linear nesse
político né
e ele faz isso e coloca lá na planta e
em só que para espanto dele quando esse
ele ver o gráfico gráfico não era linear
é um gráfico e parecia muito com gráfico
quando ele colocava em humanos né
e para trabalhar com possível porque ele
fazia ele ameaçava as pessoas com certas
perguntas pra ver se ela estava mentindo
não se estivesse mentindo criavam
estresse isso aparecer no gráfico e
ficou pensando em tão bom como é que eu
vou ameaçar a planta e aí ele vai é é a
seguinte bom talvez colocar fogo na
planta na na folha é isso cria um
estresse e enfim vai ter alguma resposta
eu vou lá observar essa resposta
bom o que a história conta é que quando
ele vai então colocar fogo na planta e
vai para o escritório da passava da da
secretária dele pegar um fósforo pra
colocar o fogo que ele vai para lá que
ele retorna ele vai olhar o gráfico e aí
o gráfico mostra que quando ele vai para
lá pensa em colocar fogo a planta acusa
é uma resposta super estranho né o
gráfico assalto aqui e ele fica
intrigado com isso é o que isso quer
dizer
bom ele fala que a partir daí a
percepção dele mudou em relação às
plantas e fim e ele começou a fazer uma
série de pesquisas e experimentos com
plantas
logicamente a comunidade científica vem
em cima dele porque escrever um livro
que haja um paper sobre isso e chamou
esse fenômeno de praia perception bom é
40 anos depois dessa história toda a
gente tem aí hoje um quadro na biologia
na época fisiologia de plantas mostrando
plantas como seres inteligentes mas te
falar uma coisa é um cara que está à
frente dessa pesquisa de inteligência em
plantas e e fala é
a capacidade de planta de se
interconectar como uma rede uma série de
fenômenos que o que mostram as
perspectivas da planta de uma forma
muito interessante é independente da
questão do batman
enfim ter validade não científica eu
como artista naquele momento eu fiquei
fascinado por essa idéia né da
capacidade da planta é se interconectar
ou ela significa algum tipo de elo né a
gente sabe que pessoas que gosta de
plantas têm uma relação super positivo
com planta de alguma forma essas plantas
respondem com a sua beleza com a sua e
com seu bem estar e e quando você não
tem essa relação às vezes elas não
respondem dessa forma enfim isso me
parecia um organismo ideal para
trabalhar dentro do estrago do das obras
que estava pensando não é
então é um pouco dada nessa perspectiva
que faz parte dessas pesquisas que
mostram respostas da planta
sensibilidade ea vários fenômenos desde
magnetismo infiltração no tempero atura
em tem uma coisa que é muito
interessante que essa capacidade de
interconexão a partir das raízes nem
parece que é um grupo de plantas se
comunicam a partir dessas raízes
mandando sinais através de fungos
através de química através de gases é
pelas folhas e e crie uma rede de
comunicação então parece que elas que
são seres que estão aptos a se comunicar
e trabalhar em rede bom plano e arte a
partir dessas idéias
eu ainda nem doutorado cria trabalho do
idt em que eu vou mostrar rapidamente
para vocês é é um trabalho onde eu uso o
mesmo procedimento que o batizou atrás
ganha com resposta galvânica cria um
sistema que o connectu na folha e faça a
leitura da resposta que a única nessa
folha
tá isso é computadore por um sistema um
microcontrolador esse é um a parte
eletrônica que foi criado por essa
captura
o que acontece é o seguinte quando você
respira quando você expira só o gás
carbônico próximo da folha ela responde
rapidamente e aí modifica as
luzes modifica o movimento faz um
movimento com as pernas que eu vou
mostrar aqui um vídeo rapidamente nessas
lusa em cima fica mais rápidas e as
perninhas que são na verdade um
guarda-chuva é virado ao contrário não é
para criar essa perna então ele parece
um trabalho muito complexo mas ele é
complexo só na questão estética mas é
muito simples né parte de usar uma série
de mecanismos que eu fui encontrando
para fazer o login ou tocando em 2010 no
brasil eu criei o o nano que este
laboratório é que a ideia era fomentar
pesquisa em arte nesse campo de
interseção com a ciência e tecnologia e
com questões ligadas à natureza onde a
gente tem uma série de atividades né
ele atua no contexto da graduação com
bolsas pibic be aqui ele tem um pouco
desses estudantes trabalhando que são
fundamentais o laboratório é o coração
do laboratório é trabalho também é a
pesquisa no contexto da pós graduação o
aluno de doutorado é mestrado e também
pós doutorado
ele foi criado nesse contexto acadêmico
para fomentar essas pesquisas de arte no
campo teórico prático tem na interseção
entre a arte ciência e tecnologia como a
fonte de inspiração o diálogo com essas
culturas ancestrais que tem muito a
dizer sobre a relação com a natureza eo
universo das forças invisíveis que nos
interconectam incorporando encorporados
a sua metodologia nessa um pouco a
filosofia do nano
isso foi uma oficina que eu fiz em mato
grosso com os índios parecis
recentemente foi fantástico levar essa
experiência é pra lá e aprender muito
com eles também
bom esse é um espaço do laboratório
agente faz aulas de da eletrônica
programação tem a ver muito com a
cultura 6 o seminário especulativos
também parte da metodologia são os
seminários onde a gente tenta coisas
como essa que eu contei do baxter
poderem entrar com o parte da
metodologia parte de um modelo ou seja é
não deixar de fora aquilo que a ciência
não concorda totalmente de uma forma
forma ortodoxa mas talvez trazer esses
modelos
e de uma forma especulativa eles podem
abrir espaço para experimentações
artísticas e quem sabe isso voltar
também para a ciência como uma forma de
conhecimento né os diálogos não
disciplinares onde essa conversa com 12
ou mais é é pesquisadores de áreas
distintas é um troca com o público não é
isso um pouco das oficinas eletrônicas
só organismo solares que a gente cria a
partir de desmontar lanternas com base é
com células solares que a gente desmonta
compra isso num camelô desmonta e usa as
peças para criar essas formas em si uma
oficina de qualquer dama
um outro ponto importante do laboratório
aqui uma das condições para você para
fazer parte do laboratório enquanto
estudante que você tenha uma idéia que
você tem um interesse né
e você traz e se desenvolve dentro do
laboratório afinado com a pesquisa do
laboratório então essa é a clara por
exemplo com certeza do corpo expansivo
que ela está trabalhando agora o alana
com esse projeto entranhas que a gente
está trabalhando com infláveis
controlado com batimento cardíaco sair
nessa parte dele está preso na orelha
dela e direção de outra imagem que fala
rapidamente que o tempo está acabando
é um exemplo botânico é um outro
trabalho já feito no contexto do
laboratório a partir dessa resposta
galvânica eu resolvi criar um robô que
responde então com uma sensação um senso
de direção direita ou esquerda de acordo
com a respiração do observador
netão ele tem esse estado de máquina
quando nada está acontecendo está
embaixo da luz quando alguém interage
com ele sai da luz e vai em direção a
essa pessoa
quando você para internação ele volta
para a luz
o encontro aborda e começa a procurar
lugares novamente telebrás fera é um dos
últimos projetos foi é apoiada pelo cnpq
ele é um sistema de donos que se
comunicam a partir de um terrário
interno foi criado dessa forma orgânica
essa criatura é uma estrutura que segura
o domo é uma estrutura parametrizada que
segura e sídon na frente decidiu montar
um pequeno terrário na interação com
esses terrário você tem então a sua
imagem transformada
nesse dólar em um pequeno vídeo para
mostrar áreas
é muita coisa a gente tem um minuto aqui
vou tentar chegar até o final
[Música]
então quando você se posiciona de fred
prince dolo é a sua imagem é ter
capturado um esqueleto e ganha essa
forma abstrata e essas cores as
partículas se transforma de acordo com a
interação com a planta
[Música]
o bom é ter uma idéia é chato projeto
que lida com abelhas a ideia você trazer
as abelhas que estão perdidas na cidade
por isso que tem esse nome sistema
habitacional para famílias sem teto que
entram nesse gênero que entra nessa
estrutura que foi criada com origami é
um trabalho da professora malu fragoso
que é a coordenadora do ano junto comigo
e e aqui você tem é as abelhas são
monitorados na fazenda o sinal vem via
rede jogadas para dentro de si
essa estrutura você pode ter um pouco a
experiência de ser uma bela enfim é bom
isso tudo é envelopado com um evento que
a gente tem anual chamado hiper
orgânicos que esse projeto onde você tem
é é um laboratório aberto onde a gente
convida artistas cientistas
pesquisadores pra trabalhar com a gente
durante três dias e criar processos que
ficam abertos que vão para a rede
ou seja se coleta dados colocam esses
dados na num servidor nós qualquer um
qualquer parte do mundo pode capturar
esses dados e fazer música fazer filme
por exemplo é pode fazer audiovisual
controlar robôs e por aí vai
segundo esse evento foi feito no museu
do amanhã este ano provavelmente vai
acontecer no ano que vem também seja
fiquem convidados
isso é uma mostra do laboratório bom e
pra fechar voltar à questão com que as
plantas podem dizer sobre educação em
arte
no começo a pesquisa dessas plantas eram
apenas uma hipótese é uma ideia como
atrair esse observador para pra esse
sistema é pressa uma relação sensível
complexa com o trabalho de arte e sua
rede através da inclusão de um organismo
vivo no sistema mas com o passar do
tempo o contato com diversas criaturas
eu fui percebendo é a riqueza é a
complexidade ea forma tão peculiar né é
particular que tenha muito a nos dizia
sá essas plantas tenta anos informar
é as plantas apresentam uma forma de
inteligência distribuída cooperativa nos
mostram uma resiliência diante das
dificuldades que as eco nos ensina que
de forma simbólica sem biótica em rede
somos mais fortes e temos uma chance de
sobreviver neste mundo caótico e
transformar tudo em transformação que
estamos construindo eu acho que é uma
grande mensagem das plantas pela forma
coletiva em rede como elas operam é
inspirado nas idéias nosso laboratório
não tem faltado para uma gestão
participativa colaborativa coerente
integrativa viva como organismo é sua
metodologia baseada no afeto
segundo redes sensível saber em suas
regionais
motivado pelas pequenas forças geradora
de grandes transformações criar a arte
com plantas e outros organismos vivos
significa perceber e se colocar na
temporalidade do outro a deixar de lado
nossa visão antropocêntrica do mundo e
buscar novas formas de convívio e
participação
educar nesse sentido é criar e inventar
novas possibilidades do mundo
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]